so this weekend's gonna be an exciting
one we got the 2021 black diamond ball
but it's a virtual experience this time
can you still party in a virtual
atmosphere how are we gonna how are we
gonna do this julie
are you kidding me you party even harder
why because you could be half
naked you only have to wear clothes at
the top you know what i'm
saying but no it's gonna be super super
duper fun i think that the party is in
the mine
it's all about the mindset uh supporting
the black diamond ball has been like a
great
experience i did it i think maybe four
years ago
and i'm happy that they've been able to
use the operative word
and pivot and make sure that the music
still has a space
you know arts and entertainment has been
impacted quite a bit with covet 19
and all the other extra stuff that's
happening but
uh to me it's all about corona
creativity
and have a wonderful time we were able
to be covered safe and actually record
this virtually so that
we could spread this love especially in
black history month
so what do you have in mind for your
performance like how
like do you have a whole glam thing
going on like what's the situation what
can we expect
a full live band like we went there
all the time yes though it's not wasn't
i wasn't like sing the track or
you know one two kumbaya like no we went
there
hardcore full on and uh for me it was
quite the experience because i had just
had surgery
and so i'm so used to running and
kicking for those who are familiar
with my performances i'm always doing
some sort of karate kick here and there
but i had to
really focus on my voice and focus on
the message of the song
um glass ceiling and that's i picked
that song off of my album the black book
in particular because so many of us
right now
have been going through things or
suffering in silence and just really
need to break through
and break through to you know to make
sure that we keep the positivity
and positive intent in the the front of
our lips in the front of our minds
it's a different day we're living in but
hey we're here and we have nothing but
opportunity
so i'm excited for this performance yeah
i mean 2020 has been
like you just said people have gone
through a lot we've experienced a lot
and we've learned a lot
and it must mean something a little bit
different this time around to be able to
raise money and support
you know um okay black youth design
initiative
and safe space 365 right absolutely you
know i really
pride myself on especially now in my
life
being at this age and stage of my life
and doing meaningful work
you know i've been there done that was
like chasing chart numbers like oh
what's the
what's the tour numbers and all these
numbers numbers numbers are so like
external for realizing that when you can
be a part of
the fabric like the quilt of change
it's a beautiful thing it feels so much
better to know that
what you're doing is actually going to
help and serve community in ways that
far out that live beyond you
yes so how can people take part where
can we watch
well it's it's going to be on on on hop
in you can definitely check there but
it's gonna be on it's gonna be on city
we're gonna it's gonna be on tv
uh for sure follow me on instagram miss
julie black and of course
the black diamond ball will be posting
and jump on
grab grab a glass of wine and give yours
give your kids some
apple juice bring your apple juice
you're also doing a um you're involved
in an interesting panel discussion as
well
coming up tomorrow right talking about
the importance of
black history and how it relates to
shaping
music and shaping basically north
america right
yes yes so excited about that panel uh
molly johnson and dan hill and you know
moderated
by um by uh rudy rudy blair
homeboy rudy blair uh there's another
awesome gentleman on the panel i'm nice
slipping me right now but he's awesome
rod i think his name is ron something
anyway you know who you are you saw us
uh but for me it was a blessing to get
on this panel to be asked to be part of
this panel because
it's generational and um i kind of rep
i'm kind of repping the young
i'm ripping the young on this panel but
we realize that experiences are actually
the same
as far as systemic racism um things that
we've gone through
as people of color of black people you
know in in media
and i you know i'm coming from the angle
of grace and of love
and opportunity to truly shift
the the narrative and to become key
holders and to have like
of gatekeepers go ahead move away we
gotta
put me in there get the youngins in
there and and let's sit at the feet of
of the elders of those who have done it
before us and went through way more
uh and to learn from them so i'm very
excited do you find
that um for younger artists people
coming up now that a lot of those
doors and those barriers that you know
you say that you've
experienced and you've that the other
artists you've talked to have
experienced are sort of opening
or breaking down it's a very good
question carlos i think that
we could see light you know the doors
cracked we're gonna
see what's going on in there they can
see and then it's up to us i think
uh to truly kick that door open it
should be easier for them
it sure needs to be and i think that uh
sometimes
there's a generation that has been
through so much struggle that they don't
help the next generation and
that's why i i don't i don't subscribe
to that i'd much rather know that the
next generation does way better
you know that's so relative as well so
subjective um but they have it
they have it easier they need they need
to the struggle is real
it's been real um but this situation
being virtual being able to reach the
entire world
you know with one click of a mouse i
think we got to look at the positive
and how this pandemic has truly created
a global neighborhood now
i love that well julie thank you so much
for the time looking forward to
everything that you're doing this
weekend and everything you're doing in
2021 i mean
like we said you're very busy well let's
change that word carlos
okay let's swap busy for productive
yes anybody can be busy
we're productive over here and so are
you
so thank you for thank you for this
space and thank you for all that you're
doing
you know as a person of color i see you
i'm grateful for you you're on the front
line for all of us so thanks carlos